tout de suite voyons l'essentiel de
l'actualité je vous le disais en dehors
du sport l'un des principaux titres de
cette actualité aujourd'hui en dehors de
la préparation des élections européennes
et de la poursuite d'un certain nombre
de meetings à travers la france c'est
bien entendu c'est bien entendu le
voyage du président de la république qui
a commencé ce matin le long rejoindre du
reste tout de suite sur place nos
envoyés spéciaux en alsace maintenant il
ya mahdi la c1 c'est un coup formidable
il va arriver à attaquer va nous faire
une révélation
j'attends rehab a dit là il ya un gros
coup aujourd'hui à nous faire caca
explosive en a chez jean françois
lachaud pour achever abadie
tout le peloton ce matin voulait nous
faire des confidences seulement voilà
impossible pour le journaliste d'être
partout à la fois heureusement côté
spectateurs des apprentis reporters nous
ont rendu un fier service
bonjour
vous dépêcher s'il vous plaît pas ce que
c'est qu'une minute là je voudrais
m'installer percolé que je vais faire
mais je perds du vélo
est-ce que vous passez
w si je peux voir des compressions ne
permettra pas si
c'est bon alors on peut partir du tout
bon
petit parc d'eau et le tour ça va oui je
vois beaucoup de points sa première fois
que vous faites et ouais je moi je vais
vivre comme ça trois antennes de ou
je connais beaucoup je vais en languedoc
et directeur après régime yayi a quand
même oui âgé de trente secondes là
faudrait que j'y aille maintenant pour
préparer parce que mon interview ça va
être trop juste un bruno cornillet je ne
suis pas journaliste
paraît-il que vous avez l'intention de
faire quelque chose de formidable
aujourd'hui
c'est continuer parce que là si c'est
qui qui doit poser les questions donc si
vous n'êtes pas journaliste antenne 2
mais ils vous ont délégué on m'a dit
simplement à tenir pour l'instant on va
revenir tout de suite il paraît que vous
êtes un joyeux lurons un joyeux drille
avec christophe certain nombre d'autres
joueurs j'adore rigoler puis surtout que
bon ici et ça me chambrer quoi c'est
tout pourquoi je sais pas
[Rires]
je suis tête à ses joueurs qui sont là
qui part assez vite quoi sur les sur les
bêtises des joueurs c'est pour ça qu'ils
aiment bien même allumé après dernière
que vous ayez fait dernière pour
l'instant la dernière elle va arriver là
alors je vais arriver dans quelques
instants sous vos yeux puisque je crois
que je sais pas quelle sera la victime
j'aurais d'abord remercié avant de vous
rendre l'antenne le docteur campora
gérard banide et tous les joueurs de
l'as monaco nous avoir reçu chez eux
aujourd'hui et notre confrère georges
bertellotti qui a largement contribué à
ce que cette émission et lieux et se
déroule dans de bonnes conditions alors
la plaisance parce que bon avec mes
camarades
[Applaudissements]
jean
michel aulas
[Rires]
s'est tenue tout simplement une
patinette sur laquelle on adjoint un
petit moteur de tondeuse à gazon mais ça
marche bien là j'entends vraiment
un petit accident ça n'était pas prévu
voilà
bernard du sial conduite aux machines à
un véritable show pas envers vais pas
vous dire les
u17 en juin qu'il n'est pas dangereux
contrairement à ce que laissait quoi les
apparences après la 1ère rider c'est un
hydro douceur et
posez la seconde place on va essayer
d'éteindre évidemment son
son champ d'investigation c'est
davantage la mer et la terre sur des
surfaces les plus plane tout ce que je
vous propose c'est de retrouver tout de
suite olivier rey du côté de pierre
fontelle on y va si vous voulez bien
rené père champagne pour retrouver
olivier rey qui va nous parler de cette
équipe de france qui visiblement sous le
soleil du côté de clairefontaine olivier
enfants temps plutôt clément à
clairefontaine pour ce début de stage
préparatoire à france israël madame
monsieur bonsoir et bien oui un temps
variable aujourd'hui sur l'ensemble de
la région il pleut il pleut les
températures étaient pourtant clémentel
été comprise entre 22 et 24 degrés pour
demain matin
à temps mi figue mi raisin les
températures seront comprises entre 11
et 13 degrés pour demain après midi même
programme dans instable avec des
éclaircies des averses et des orages le
coup les ouvertures varieront entre 20
et 22 degrés le vent sera de secteur sud
ouest nord-ouest modéré à assez fort en
bref un dimanche bien maussade en
perspective mais avec quelques
éclaircies
donc qu'ils votent non il va profiter je
vous souhaite une bonne soirée du
répertoire des incidents sur le plateau
on est en direct vous savez ce que c'est
vous avez vu comme nous on n'a rien dit
mais on a les pieds dans cinq ou dix
centimètres d'eau mais les intempéries
vous le découvrez maintenant à l'antenne
donc malheureusement nous allons devoir
interrompre cette émission je ne sais
pas ce qui va se passer mais restez avec
nous vous en saurez plus au cas où
l'émission ne pourrait pas reprendre
nous retrouverons bien entendu notre
deux candidats et sur qui persistent sur
les îles britanniques dirige vers nous
un régime sec et froid le ciel va rester
bien dégagé et on va croiser les doigts
est ce qu'on perd
alors c'est quoi ça maintenant ça c'est
l'accord d'aujourd'hui
alors demain je vais tenter de vous
expliquer la situation
demain c'est un ciel de traîne qui
s'établira l'ensemble du pays avec des
averses assez forte toujours des chutes
de neige en montagne
salon voilà non
bon
génie des averses qui sait peut-être
qu'ils aient mois alors on va y arriver
alors des averses notamment sur le
relief avec des pluies qui resteront
accrochées
voilà voilà l'écart alors des averses
avec des chutes de neige sur le relief à
partir de quinze 100 m un ciel couvert
sur le massif central et des chutes de
neige à basse altitude sur les vosges le
sucre
et l'eau
mesdames messieurs je vous propose de
vous retrouver ce soir à 20h40 oui météo
alors on vient au bilan 87 quelque chose
encore très chic c'est une fin d'année
très très chic à la bourse de paris je
pas qu'il y avait une crise il n'y a pas
eu de crise enfin pas mon avis regardez
comme ils sont heureux autour de ce qui
était la corbeille et surtout autour de
jean centrale allemande est intervenue
ce matin mais cela n'a pas empêché le
dollar de côté 1 marc 57 95 pour les
actions ce n'est pas la fête malgré les
confettis et les serpentins traditionnel
la tendance est à la baisse en hausse à
londres et à paris à 80 4600 francs le
lingot d'un kilo a perdu a gagné 300
francs et à 5 169 francs le napoléon a
gagné 8 francs cette fois c'est officiel
les socialistes contre attaque jospin
secret
sur le terrain est glissant de l'
affaire du sang contaminé l'eau ps
n'entend pas être le seul à chuter
depuis jeudi il prépare sa contre
offensive et rien ne semble devoir
l'arrêter
car les socialistes cette fois non pas
d'états d'âme alors on savait jusqu'ici
ce qu'il fallait faire pour passer la
neige des pneus à clous mais rien de tel
avec l'outil dans l'ex-yougoslavie
resteront inchangés depuis hier c'est
aussi les risques de la guerre dans
notre studio à moscou image
impressionnante il s'agit de cinq mille
officiers de l'ex armée soviétique en
plein désarroi j'ai débuté avec une très
belle chatte et je savais absolument
pense que c'était gelé menée en
exposition tout à fait
innocente le président russe doit aussi
faire face à un autre mécontentement
c'est celui des ménagères lorsque les
produits sont de plus en plus rares et
que les prix grimpent et quand j'ai vu
ma chatte sortir première best in show
voyez des choses que je savais pas ce
que ça voulait dire et je me suis
retrouvée oui c'est en fait j'ai mis le
doigt dans un engrenage
et maintenant j'y suis juste allée paul
george jonathan et gilbert si belle les
inventeurs du slip éminence ont
découvert lors d'un voyage en argentine
que les cavaliers là-bas portait un
renfort devant leur slip ouille ouille
ouille ils ont donc créé la ligne
kangourou pour son 50e anniversaire
éminence a re créer le même modèle bien
entendu au bout les jours triplement
renforcé à la poche
aussi croyez qu'on ne refuse d'en ne
recule devant rien pour vous informer et
bien l'atmosphère il y en avait assez
peu parce que nous avons renvoi
vous
vous n'entendez plus de constance bah il
se passe vraiment quelque chose on va
essayer vous m'entendez daniel la non
j'ai pas l'impression que le dialogue
qui s'établit entre moi et daniel one
qui se demande un petit peu ce qui se
passe autour d'elle voilà c'est ça
l'information en direct ça on a
quelquefois des surprises laniel est-ce
que vous m'entendez cette fois ci je
vous entends je sais ça irait très bien
c'est parfait vous pouvez continuer on a
eu un petit problème de lumière mais
vous êtes aussi belle comme ça qu'avec
plus de lui quand il explique on va voir
eh bien là c'est là vous allez voir nous
allons voir cela donc le sang des autres
claude chabrol
je crois que c'est la meilleure
l'année de tous les dangers
c'est assez extraordinaire vous en
voulez pas
nous aussi comme quoi tout le monde a
droit de se tromper avec ceux qui font
rien qui ne se trompent jamais je voir
si on à l'extrait du bon film sinon ça
va encore plus intrigué nos spectateurs
parisiens ont mis au pouvoir le sang des
autres je n'avais jamais osé mettre des
philippines
on était en train de parler
tranquillement des allemands sur la
place de la concorde et on a vu arriver
des japonais est pas du tout sur la
place de la concorde mais plutôt sur le
pont de la rivière kwaï cela
s'est moins bien c'est quand même nom
mais le soin il est plus beau que
l'arrivée voilà
mais on n'est pas dans une mission de
promotion non non non non non non
est-ce que je peux pas
il a vu thierry lhermitte chez puis
les mâles par nier que c'est pas oui
alors revenons à mitterrand et puis là
ses dernières lectures
voilà je commence par la fin pour savoir
si j'irai au panthéon les années
mitterrand oui vous êtes quand même
vous l'avais envoyé au président non je
peux être que l'éditeur l'a fait mais
ils partent alors qu'avant il veut vous
envoyer un coup de couteau la première
c'est le genre de mec dangereux
de l'interdît
on a eu des propos un peu de gauche
épices bas
il a les cheveux coupés
on a l'impression qu'il est au régime en
effet sont les un petit peu la
partie
regardez sa chaise
et oui alors est ce que quelqu'un veut
te trouves que c'est il est allé trop
loin là non pas du tout ben oui tu ne
veux pas te parle de kabila
je parle de cabu la cab et alors vous
avez mis cinq ans pour ça qu'ils se
disent
pourquoi est ce que les producteurs sont
à ce point rétifs c'est parce que je
suis
c'est pas vrai et que tout le monde est
content parce que j'ai raté ma vie alors
vous écrivez aussi un livre qui
s'appelle les chiens est-ce que vous
pouvez expliquer que cha là les chats le
thème de ce roman est bien le thème mais
c'est vraiment vous l'avez les noms bon
parce qu'il est pas sorti ah oui quand
sortie c'est vrai et bien
c'est
très risqué
c'est très très osé c'est
une
une star de cinéma
une momie aux beaux yeux
et qui est homosexuel et a travesti
cosmonaute et cinéaste qui sait
le pire c'est que vous inventez rien
parce que j'étais libre là vous êtes
également sur scène à partir de la
semaine prochaine au casino de paris
pour un nouveau spectacle
s kiddies mars alors on vous voit
fonctionner comme vous fonctionnez là
c'est à dire en perpétuel décalage par
rapport à la réalité de la situation
puisque vous êtes sur un plateau de
télévision dans un journal a priori
sérieux avec un journaliste qui vous
pose des questions sérieuses la question
je vous aime pas non michel sont
un peu grossière du tout que je connais
faire émerger un coup parce que je sais
c'est un professionnel de première c'est
là ça c'est ce que bref vous avez fait
là tout à l'heure que c'était à mon avis
pas admissible oui mais on le fait quand
je vais le lâcher pour la paix non mais
c'est moi qui voulais vous
demander
pardon ou non en fait je sais pas je
voulais que jouent les barrages de vos
papilles et non merci un petit chèque
comme je sais qu'il faut pas dépasser
les 1000 francs ou non mais on déborde
beaucoup voilà c'est 999 francs par jeu
ses passions que le oui oui ça prend
juste impossible
merci voilà merci de vos cadeaux il faut
rendre pénalement pour une émission ce
soir il faut pas qu'on déborde dans un
petit quart d'heure je savais pas qu'on
fait payer
[Musique]
on ne fait pas ces gens de réflexion
dans un quart d'heure
c'est l'histoire de deux anciennes
vedettes de la télévision pour se
convertit justement dans l'escroquerie
décidément je rappelle le 22h30 par à
tata avec donc négative vers 23h45 non
je ne peux pas le dire dernier journal
en compagnie de rémi roche demain à 7h50
gérard leclerc recevra mon confrère
alain duhamel qui parlera de son dernier
livre les peurs française après le paris
dakar et le journal des courses la natte
de la météo de ne payent rien elle va
être content d'avoir deux bogeys les
doors ce journal vers 20h50 millions
culture donc exceptionnel avec
alessandrini sin suivi d'un téléfilm
nadal était une oeuvre de l'écrivain le
prends dix ers de l'anniversaire à 2000
gré elle attend le dicton alain sa
renault ça roule demain retrouvez
palamara 13 heures et à 20 heures et
tout de suite pour et on est souple elle
est donc de suivre le sourire de
nathalie rihouet sourire à la grimace
dans le sud où pluie et nuages sont au
programme demain génériques
bonsoir voila bonne soirée sur antenne 2
à demain 20 heures
[Musique]